on y est
stephen harper soutient que les années
où pierre elliott trudeau était premier
ministre
le déficit a grimpé en flèche pour
atteindre 9% du produit intérieur brut
dans les années 80 vérification faite
c'est fou pour le neuf pour cent selon
le ministère des finances du canada le
déficit budgétaire
en réalité atteint un sommet de 8 1% du
pib en 1984 1985
stephen harper laisse donc sous entendre
que le déficit budgétaire avait atteint
41 milliards de dollars alors qu'il
était de 37 milliards de dollars en dix
huit ans de pouvoir les conservateurs de
brian mulroney et de stephen harper ont
enregistré au total 16 déficit et 2
surplus pour un déficit net de près de
420 milliards de dollars soulignons par
contre que deux récessions sont survenus
pendant leurs mandats respectifs en 14
ans de pouvoir les libéraux de paul
martin de jean chrétien et en comptant
les deux dernières années de pierre
elliott trudeau ont enregistré quant à
eux cinq déficit budgétaire mais neuf
surplus pour un déficit net de 63
milliards de dollars
le ministère des finances précise qu'on
ne peut comparer les données antérieures
à 1983 1984
parce que les méthodes comptables ont
changé la conjoncture économique est
responsable en partie des déficits
budgétaires en pleine crise financière
sous le gouvernement harper le canada a
connu son plus important déficit en
chiffres absolus soit 55 milliards de
dollars
ici de riches depuis mai fera du cadam
orient